one aspect of the mind beyond subjective
experience consciousness maybe even
information processing these are facets
of the mind that are good descriptions
let's just put those to the side for now
this fourth fact of the mind has a
definition not just a description this
facet of the mind can be defined this
way the emergent self-organizing
embodied and relational process that
regulates the flow of energy and
information and if we take that apart
step by step we can see that the system
we're talking about is called a complex
system that means it's open to
influences from outside of itself as
capable of being chaotic and it's
nonlinear meaning small inputs have
large and difficult to predict results
when you have those three
characteristics math says that system is
a complex system and once we're in the
realm of complex systems we find that
these complex systems have what are
called emergent properties they're the
interaction of the elements of the
system give rise to these properties
that cannot be reduced to the singular
elements that are interacting to give
rise to them the notion that complex
systems have emergent properties is
sometimes responded to by various
scientists or even the general public as
very confusing sometimes even ridiculous
what I do in the book mind is I actually
put some quotes from some scientists to
actually see emergence as not only a
scientific property of complex systems
but as a necessary way of understanding
what it is that emerges for example why
clouds have the beautiful ways that they
unfold across the sky that's an emergent
property of water molecules and air
molecules that form the clouds and the
emergent property there's
self-organization that's determined
how it unfolds so when you come to the
emergent property of self-organization
then you also get people saying well
that just doesn't feel right it doesn't
feel intuitive and I totally share that
initial response self-organization has a
strange reality where number one as an
emergent property it's the interaction
of the elements of the system in this
case energy and information flow that is
giving rise to it that's what an
emergent property means it can't be
reduced to the singular elements but as
a self-organizing emergent property it
means it's arising from something that's
the emergent part but then it's turning
back and regulating that from which it
is arising which is completely
non-intuitive that's called a recursive
feature cursive means that feedbacks on
it it has a feedback group with the
feedback system feedbacks it feeds back
when itself so even there you know as
I'm speaking to you I'm doing an
assessment of what's going on it takes
feedbacks know it's feedback so what
that means is that arising from the
system is self-organization it then
regulates the interaction of the
elements of the system so that
self-organization is then continually
influencing itself which is completely
counterintuitive so here's the amazing
thing it's a proven property of our
universe that complex systems have this
recursive property to it it's probably
why people have not really gone to these
emergent properties because especially
self-organization it's not intuitive the
second reason I think people haven't
gone here is because this definition of
the mind as the emergent self-organizing
embodied and relational process that
regulates the flow of energy information
is placing the mind in quote two places
at once
within your body and between you and
other people and you and the planet so
this irritates people because first of
all
many people point to their head when
they talk about their mind and they
place the mind inside the skull but even
if you kept the mind only inside the
skin encased body you'd feel okay with
the word embodied and many people do
however once you say it's both embodied
and relational you get into this really
interesting new way of thinking because
you say how could one thing mind be both
within in between in two places well
here's a way to think about it our
fundamental element we're proposing is
energy and information flow now if you
think about that the skull nor the skin
are impermeable boundaries for energy
and information to flow so you may think
of them as two places but it's one
system energy and information flow and
it's happening in many different
locations
[Music]
you